it is the director who's indelible touch
is reflected on every frame it is the
director who's shot by shot scene by
scene day by day works with every member
of the crew to further the story and it
is the vision of the director that takes
an ordinary movie and turns it into a
work of art these four men and Greta
Gerwig created their own masterpieces
this year for achievement in directing
[Applause]
Christopher Nolan Dunkirk
Jordan Peele get out
Greta Gerwig ladybird
Paul Thomas Anderson phantom thread
[Applause]
guillermo del toro the shape of my
[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to Guillermo del Toro
[Applause]
is the fourth nomination for guillermo
del toro and his first
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
i I am Annie I am an immigrant like
Alphonse run I'll handle my compadres
like il like Salma and like many many of
you and in the last 25 years I've been
living in a country all over owned part
of it is here for a reason you're
opposed everywhere because I think that
the greatest thing or our doors and our
industry does is to erase the lines in
the sand we should continue doing that
when the world tells us to make them
deeper the place I like to live the most
is at for Searchlight because in 2014
they came to listen to a mad pitch with
some drawings and the story and a
maquette and they believe that a fairy
tale about an amphibian God and mutant
woman and Dawn in the style of Douglas
Sirk and a musical and a thriller was a
sure bet I want to thank the people that
have come with me all the way kami
Robert Gary Wayne and George and my kids
and I want to say like Jimmy Cagney said
once my mother thanks you my father
thanks you my brothers and sister thank
you and I thank you very much thank you